– Selma, du hast auch Fotos mitgebracht.
– Ja. Also, die Fotos zeigen meine
Heimatstadt in Syrien.
Das ist die Straße,
in der wir gewohnt haben.
– Wirklich schön. Wenn ich das sehe,
denke ich sofort an Urlaub.
Während Selma spricht,
könnt ihr gerne Notizen machen.
– Ja, es gab viele Touristen,
als noch Frieden war.
Aber jetzt ist alles anders.
Viele Häuser und Wohnungen sind zerstört.
Sehr viele Menschen
sind vor dem Krieg geflohen,
und es kommen natürlich auch schon
lange keine Touristen mehr.
– Willst du wieder zurück?
Denkst du oft an deine Heimat?
– Ich denke sogar sehr oft an meine Heimat.
Hier ist es auch schön, aber ich möchte
gerne wieder zurück nach Hause.
Aber im Moment ist das nicht möglich.
Wir versuchen jetzt,
hier ein neues Leben zu beginnen.
– Schicke Krone.
– Ja, das war mein
sechzehnter Geburtstag.
Daran erinner ich mich gut.
Wir haben richtig toll gefeiert.
Es gab so viel zu essen, dass allen ’am
Abend ganz schlecht war.
– Ist das Ihre Familie?
– Ja genau. Das ist meine Familie.
Das kleine Mädchen bin ich.
Das war für mich ein ganz besonderer Tag,
weil ich das erste Mal mein
neues Kleid anhatte.
Es war etwas Besonderes. Meine Eltern
hatten nicht sehr viel Geld damals.
– Vielen Dank für die tollen
Geschichten und die Fotos.
Das war’s auch schon wieder.
– Darf ich mit Ihnen und Selma
noch ein Foto machen?
– Klar.